largas horas de espera en el frío para
venir a donar sangre aquí en mí pero
estamos en uno de los centros de
donación de sangre del país y las filas
de espera no se reducen al cuarto día
del conflicto entre rusia y ucrania mil
personas vienen acá cada día a donar su
sangre y las cantidades recolectadas son
considerables una medida de 400 litros
cada jornada los ucranianos con los
cuales hablamos nos dijeron que querían
ayudar a su país y su ejército como
podían y se puede hablar de un verdadero
ímpetu solidario como como es para
ayudar a los militares
yo sé al cien por ciento que es
importante esa ayuda y apoyo porque
están aquí y necesitan nuestras almas
primero voy a dar sangre y después me
voy a enlistar en el ejército para
defender el país e ir a enfrentarme a
los ocupantes rusos
si usted tiene buena salud debería donar
sangre y si usted tiene la posibilidad
agarre un arma y vaya hacia la primera
línea cada uno debe hacer lo que puede
[Música]
existen muchos centros de donaciones de
sangre como este en el país en mi pro la
tercera ciudad de ucrania los médicos
tratan de acumular las reservas
suficientes de sangre que serán luego
enviadas a donde se necesite